[Music]
actress and four-time Grammy Award
winner that's Olivia newton-john right
there she's a superstar whose appeal
bridges generations she's known as sandy
from the 1978 blockbuster grease with
John Travolta and four chart-topping
hits like magic but if she told us in an
interview for CBS Sunday morning her
latest role in the fight against cancer
may be the most enduring
as we stand here today you look pretty
to me I'm not afraid of anything right
now Olivia newton-john has mastered
living in the moment we nee think even
as she battles breast cancer for a third
time I think when you're dealing with
something when you have a diagnosis like
this how do you stay in the moment and
stay present and not let it consume you
and worry you okay
denial he's really good he's really
healthy it was consuming my day and
after time I went you know what I had
need to enjoy my life so I'm going to
eat a cookie if I want it because the
joy of life and everyday living has to
be a part of that healing process as
well so I've chosen that path to be
grateful and to feel good about things
because the other side is not so good
and I don't I'm not a victim and I don't
want to be one I feel that what has
happened to me is had purpose that
purpose is raising money and awareness
for the Olivia newton-john cancer
wellness and Research Center in
Melbourne you said one of your dreams is
to see the end of cancer in your
lifetime do you think that will happen
I'm prey for it mm-hmm you know I think
that we're getting closer to better
treatments kind of treatments I'm hoping
that we can do more plant medicine
research at my Center we have a grant
from the government which is amazing to
do a two million dollar cancer research
study with our patients for well-being
so all these dreams are coming true this
November Julien's auction house will
sell off her most iconic costumes some
of the proceeds going towards her Center
including a dress from the physical tour
get physical physically Ernie's famous
skin tight pants from a movie Grease now
this I see this and I see stars right
it's like how many people think Olivia
can get the pants
we believe in you Olivia and in case
you're wondering they still fit that's
amazing that's amazing you have a
favorite Olivia newton-john song one
that stands out for you that says every
time I sing that or every time I hear
that I really love that one well yes I
guess I honestly love you would be one
of those songs
because I was closed to my show with it
and every time I sing it there'd be
something new and beautiful in in the
lyric for me even after a lifetime of
making beautiful music Olivia
newton-john says she's not done yet and
I kept telling my buddy we're gonna keep
going we got another 20 years to go
so keep well folks I wish that I got
lots to do he's got lots to do she just
turned 21 yes she's been diagnosed with
stage 4 cancer which is the highest
there is no Stage five and she's very
well aware of that she said I don't
focus on that I focus on the now and I
live in the moment but that song Anthony
you probably know the answer to this I
always thought it was have you ever been
mellow it's have you never been mellow
did you know that yes I knew you did
power positive thinking you know it's a
positive thing to me makes it I swear
you just said she just turned 21 it just
may feel 21 did I say 21 I think you did
okay we'll go with that plus 50 you're
gonna have to play the tape on that and
I did say 20 well I don't know it's a
testament to how she she exudes that